welcome everybody i received an
incredible amount of reaction and
feedback to yesterday's segment where we
looked at some of the things that
attendees at a recent trump rally were
saying cultists and conspiracy theorists
visibly disoriented people clueless
individuals ignorant folks etc
and a ton of reaction from you about
what is fundamentally you know we
when hillary clinton talked about
deplorables
these are deplorables there's no
question about it these are some of the
worst of the worst participants to the
extent that they're even really
participating in the american political
landscape and many of you wrote to me
and said david how do we fix this how do
we fix what what possible solution could
there be to the fact that these
neo-reactionaries as i call them
um are increasingly prevalent and
present in american politics and as bad
as things are already and as bad as
things got under donald trump
we are i think many of you were reacting
to
the realization that we're only a few
house and senate votes away
from the absolute worst of the worst
people like marjorie taylor greene and
lauren bober and others gaining total
power of the united states political
system they have some power right now
but fortunately because you've got a
whole bunch of democrats and then also
some republicans with whom i disagree
but who aren't crazy
like the conspiracy theorists
they don't have total power people like
green and bober but we're close right i
mean if we saw a little bit of a shift
they would actually have real power in
the united states
and
look at the struggle we're in
to defeat this complete and total
irrationality it shouldn't be this
difficult these are folks you know in a
sane country
it wouldn't be this difficult to keep
people
like marjorie taylor green madison
cothor and lauren bobert even trump
himself in a sane country
trump coming out and saying people are
flushing toilets 10 times and mexicans
are rapists and criminals we would have
said wow that's crazy but this person
never has a chance
they're not going to win the primary
never mind become president but in this
country because of the electorate it is
that difficult in a normal universe
reality and simple logic
would be the overwhelming favorite to
win
it would be the default and it would be
the norm and yet here we are
we're teetering really on the brink of
becoming a country run by people who
believe our major problems are
satan worshipping politicians and
celebrities having to flush toilets 10
to 15 times
theories that aren't even being taught
to kids at school being public energy
number one
athletes who kneel
whether m m's are attractive enough to a
fox news host supposed socialism and
communism
a couple of dr seuss books that are
being taken out of circulation bill
gates adrenochrome
you know mexican refugees and immigrants
and their children
climate change mitigation as the enemy
not as something that we need to do but
that's the enemy
windmills causing cancer woke math
jewish space lasers i mean like think
about that's not a short list i could go
on there are even more imaginary
problems i could tell you about and the
dangerous part comes in when we think
about who these folks most remind us of
and now i'm talking about the cult
followers
dealing with cultists
doesn't always end well for them or for
others
and you know think about waco the waco
siege also known as the waco massacre
when law enforcement uh went to the
compound that belonged to the religious
sect the branch davidians think about
ruby reid ruby ridge the 11 day siege
in 1992
um when uh it was another one of these
cult elements we don't even need to talk
about the entire thing
jim jones and the people's temple and
the mass
murder-suicide
heaven's gate the religious movement uh
again and i i believe there the term
mass suicide is more appropriate maybe
it's murder-suicide um donald trump got
like 47 percent of the popular vote in
2020. if we imagine that half of those
voters are cultists you're talking about
35 million people
if you say well only a quarter of them
are real cultists it's still 17 and a
half million people if only an eighth of
them are cultists it's still close to 10
million people so the main question that
many of you are concerned with and you
keep asking me is how do we defeat the
insanity we all know that with the
republicans and these neo-reactionaries
it's all
ignorant unthinking projection and
hypocrisy and double standards but we
know that just pointing out hey that's a
double standard like you say you're
against regulation but now you're saying
regulate social media and regulate
businesses by telling them you can't
require vaccines it's a double standard
that doesn't work they don't care it's a
feature not a bug that they claim these
are our principles but they abandon them
as soon as it's inconvenient you can't
really use their own arguments against
them because they don't care
so is the solution to instead focus on
how these people
bring no solutions ever they just attack
imaginary problems maybe that should be
the focus tell us exactly how you would
do x and they don't and they can't and
they have no ideas maybe that's the
approach i don't know
but think about what a country run by
these people would look like it would
without a doubt be essentially a white
christian heterosexual
reactionary right-wing country period
we can't ignore
the effect that barack obama's
presidency as a half-black man had on
many of these these folks as upset as
they were
that a liberal
black man was in the white house
we saw that they
immediately had to start manufacturing
stories about obama's character flaws
because fundamentally it was never about
policy
oh he went to a church that we don't
like look at the things look at people
trump's associated with he wore a tan
suit he's an elitist who wants dijon
mustard
uh he wasn't born here birth certificate
etc
and what donald trump did he didn't
create these people but the trump white
house gave these people
the language to express their
reactionary nature
with some plausible deniability that
they had been searching for for decades
for so long they couldn't say the things
they were really thinking because they
were so vile and disgusting and
xenophobic and racist and whatever and
trump provided them a language
that includes
america first
dealing with immigration we're going to
fix trade all of these different things
that gave them the language to say the
things they had been thinking a long
time without being totally branded as
what they actually are
just remember
um they don't want
to talk to
each other
and actually have the open dialogue on
ideas they claim they want to have
what they actually want is to impose
their ideas from above and silence
everything else while claiming that they
are for free speech that's what a lot of
the battle on social media is right now
their priority is own the libs
suffocate the ideas of the libs
and that's the the ultimate goal it's
the silence and at the end of the day
if they get their way
where do they imagine everybody who
isn't like them will go like in their
vision of america do
the people they don't like stay with
some kind of second-tier status well
that's horrifying do they imagine
everybody else leaves a
a peaceful segregation as some white
nationalists talk about i don't know
you can't possibly come up with an
answer to that type of question when
you're not dealing with rational human
thinking individuals to begin with and
at the end of the day politics
requires some compromise and it requires
some rationality
but these neo-reactionaries believe that
they are acting some of them believe
they're acting literally in the name of
god with others it's a pseudo-deity
that's at the head of their cult it
could be trump or it could be marjorie
taylor green or whoever so they won't
compromise they can't compromise and i'm
as scared as you are about the path
forward if you have some idea
about how to productively deprogram
these people
i still want to put together what might
be some kind of coherent strategy let me
know
one of our sponsors is blinkist who's
been supporting the david pakman show
longer than any other sponsor blinkist
is the app that lets you listen to or
read an entire non-fiction book in just
15 minutes blinkist is the way to absorb
those books you can't make time for
blinkist takes top non-fiction titles
pulls out the book's key takeaways and
insights and gives it to you in the form
of a text or audio explainer that you
can consume in 15 minutes with blinkist
now you actually do have time to learn
about all the things you've been wanting
to tackle on the blinkist app i just
listened to this is your mind on plants
by the great michael pollan
super interesting the history of
caffeine and so many other things
blinkist has you covered on podcast 2
blinkist takes long episodes of popular
podcasts and distills them into audio
you can listen to in 15 minutes with
blinkist you can become knowledgeable
about so many different things you can
have conversations with people about
more topics blinkist makes you more
well-rounded
try blinkist for free and get 25 off a
subscription go to blinkist.com
pacman the link is down below